I love an insulated mug and here is why.
I would normally spend my day reheating my coffee several times.
So let's go out in the garden and see why
I'd always leave my mug sitting on top of a pole while I'm gardening.
I get carried away with gardening
and time I get back to it is always cold.
There's several features I like about this cup
that keeps my coffee hot.
And it even has a spout, so if I want to put some ice cold water in it,
it's easy to drink from.
Makes me think that my disabled mother would probably like this
to drink her hot tea in.
Click buy now and see if you have any coupons in your car.
Check out all the cute colours I have.
I think I'm gonna order a pink one for my mum.